let's talk about the screen just give me
two two new phones a little bigger than
this and one even bigger than that do
people want these larger screens how
well are they going to leave it or not I
mean apples almost two years behind the
leaders with respect to the form factor
in our opinion this is gonna be enough
to drive a massive upgrade cycle of the
existing installed base of iphone users
so yeah we kind of joke you know for the
past year this is gonna be the mother
lode of all Apple upgrade cycles so even
if inches though that's big I mean
that's phablet if I mean it competes
with the iPad it does the ice and meanie
yeah the ipad mini seven point nine
inches no question but the largest
smartphone that we've seen out there
that we actually thought was
economically sensible was the LG G flex
we saw that a mobile world congress is
past here it's six inches in but it
curves so it kind of curves across the
mandible it fits pretty nicely we didn't
think that was too big I think the 5.5
inch will be fine not now it's gonna be
a question to see which of the Apple
user community likes better is going to
be the 4.7 inch or the 5.5 our best
guess is probably gonna be a 50-50 split
right now Apple to tremont your shopping
Apple didn't seem to get it right last
time when their atler loewen phone sort
of underperformed for them um what does
Apple do you know one of the only thing
we don't talk about it much is how well
Apple's manage its supply chain what
does this mean when they don't really
know what's gonna take off and yet
they're trying to launch this in a
bigger way than ever before they're
taking a greater risk than ever you
bring up a huge point Corey because if
you think about it there's 300 million
iphone users out there the existing
install base of which we estimate about
a hundred million are not eligible to
upgrade so that means there's 200
million within the existing install base
that's ready to migrate to the larger
form factor canvas typically what we've
seen with the iphone launches recently
it launches that same quarter at peaks
and then it comes down launches peaks
then comes out now there's going to be
so much wood behind that arrow we think
that this is gonna be 60 70 80 million
units for quite some time so it's gonna
be a multi quarter refresh cycle so we
think it's going to drive tremendous eps
expansion so what about other new
features what else could Apple do
besides screen size to move the needle
there's been a lot of talk about
extending battery life not much battery
innovation over the last several
Cades that you know I just read a story
about you UBM in the New York Times
about Wi-Fi charging you know wirelessly
essentially what about this kind of new
technology yeah my my iPhone 5 is less
than fifty percent charge on the day so
far yes it started the data like you we
got a long ways to go so I think number
one obviously is gonna be the form
factor larger screen number two will be
better improved battery performance
screen a better battery and a little bit
big you'll be physically bigger badder
it'll be thinners a lot more power yeah
thinner but we have a greater surface
area so we can cram more batteries in
there you crack it crack open this new
iPhone 6 it's gonna be all battery so
well that's the case now if you were if
when you break these phones open it is a
fact is almost all the unit inside of
the battery yeah we're gonna have
expanded surface area so the battery
life will increase pretty dramatically
in our view then finally number three is
just gonna be the updated operating
system it'll be I OS 8 and so you know
frankly we don't see a tremendous amount
of innovation on the actual device
regardless it's gonna be selling like
hotcakes it's gonna sell anyway but I
guess you know you wonder what's it
gonna take to get something more I
talked about NFC and then just just
other things like that that move the
needle example Samsung's throwing all
kinds of junk another phone right
they've got a bra like a broader in
their phone they've got the waterproof
stuff they do you expect apple to
respond to some of that and throw in
some chips and things of new
possibilities think about it this way
the cell phone market globally is a two
billion unit market now smartphones for
the first time ever are over fifty
percent so we're over a billion units so
this is largely a mature market thing
about pcs other than the form factor
over the past five or ten years has much
really changed not that much right we
tried this little netbook thing
obviously that didn't work the
fundamental form factor of a pc is not
really evolving we feel smartphones have
reached a similar point of maturation so
Eddy Cue Apple executive says it's the
most exciting product line he's seen in
25 years at Apple coming up Tim Cook
agrees with him what else could there be
is it will and i watch come out this
fall is there something more is it just
the the new phones i think you know that
though
for the commentary from the senior
management team obviously is trying to
rally not only the troops internally but
also the public is lost for me yeah I
think yeah toodle-blue iPhone be more
exciting than the original at the end of
the day nothing is gonna move the needle
from an apple perspective with the
exception of new updated iPhones I mean
if you think about it you know Apple
ecosystem now they're gonna generate
over two hundred billion dollars of
revenue next year ship over 200 million
phones so even if the iWatch is
phenomenally successful Grand Slam
success it's not gonna move the needle
from a financial perspective in our
opinion you know I went back and looking
at the revenue numbers for the iPad in
his first year in the iPad it was an
incredible success of lights of which
technology has probably never seen even
compared to the phone or the ipod or
anything the if they were to launch the
ipad with the same success that they had
in the first year this year to a much
bigger Apple would be less than five
percent of revenues that's an inch in
way to look at it's just it's just they
couldn't do anything to match the
success they've had or in a reasonable
one when you have sweetheart carrier
subsidy deals more than 2x industry
average coupled with incremental resale
of NAND flash in some cases up to
eighty-five percent excess gross margins
this is both this is on the iphone it's
so hard to compete with anything else
and considering that that global pete
are a global cell phone market is a two
billion unit market opportunity you just
can't you can't get anything else to
move the needle for many positive threat
to help them see what you think so
t-mobile's out there with the strategy
of untying the the user to the contract
meaning the users actually paying full
cost of the phone you've got smart
phones that have less features and say
the Samsung Galaxy or the iphone but are
much lower cost does that start to eat
away at the business or Apple and
Samsung have dominated sort of you know
most of the business well I think new
new pay schemes are going to be a thing
of the future no question but at the end
of the day smartphone costs 600 700
dollars without a contract well if you
sign a two-year contract that's going to
be twenty five hundred dollars so so you
know there's a little chunk of the price
that is actually the phone the real cost
to the end customer is obviously the
subscription service and so I don't
expect
much change to the overall SPS of the
high-end segment of the phone smartphone
market which that where Apple competes
the general smartphone industry is about
a 300 300 and $35 ASP over a billion
units you know so Apple plays at a
category of twice at